hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara's never seen and
today I am watching Dark City yes I know
I was in the matrix reviews for
nostalgia critic and that they mentioned
Dark City and then I played a stranger
but no I've not seen Doc City it's got
Jennifer Connelly in it and so I've got
some Jennifer Connelly hair going on I
love her this has been described to me
as cool gritty hard to understand slow
and also like a you know a more gloomy
matrix-matrix is a really cool idea I
haven't seen it in so long I should do
like a Tamra has seen but she doesn't
remember it of the matrix because I know
it was just such a cultural phenomenon
and like I said I haven't seen two or
three and I really don't remember the
first I just know that they're living in
little pods spoilers and yes take the
red or the blue pill Laurence Fishburne
okay I am wondering if I'm gonna be on
the side of like oh my god is brilliant
and beautiful or if I'm gonna be on the
side of like oh yeah it's cool I don't
just don't really get it cuz that's
generally this side of us we will see
let's do it
[Music]
hello John Murdoch need to get rid of
the hair right hello John feel like Judy
Garland and that one song shuttle come
on get happy enough fun southern Isle
get away that was coming Lee interesting
it was beautifully confusing
it was ethnically
in the middle if I were someone who was
like very good at reviewing movies or
like very into film study or like knew
anything about its cinema at all I would
really get into picking this apart ends
studying it I think I imagine that this
is something you tackle in school if you
go to film school because it's like it's
very interesting such a cool idea and
then also there are some weird-ass parts
about this movie and just weird chunks
of exposition and awesome villains who
are also like maybe a little silly
sometimes and like a really cool lead
character who you don't really get the
sense of who he is but you still like
him the whole theme of the movie is that
you need to figure out who you are
and if you know everything that you know
about yourself is taken away from you is
there like this shred of your style
itself still there and what makes you
you what makes you who you are and it's
just done and told in such a class way
this sets are amazing it's got like this
gotham bioshock like dark yucky night
always 30 days of night scary towns gary
asked town you know dark city the
scariest town you know the one John
Murdock wakes up in a bathtub full of
water and there's a dead woman in the
apartment that he's in and he has no
memory which is just fun that's a blast
he's being hunted by the police for the
murder of this woman and turns out
several other women he's also being kind
of pursued by his wife that he doesn't
remember and also he is being heavily
heavily followed by these pale white men
called the strangers who control the
dark and the daytime and
lack thereof and everyone and everything
again it's just fun you find out through
a series of weird guesses and then some
kind of clumps of exposition that the
strangers are controlling everything
they reset memories they kind of switch
things the whole time you're kind of
questioning if Jennifer Connelly's
character and John Murdock I don't know
his name dr. John Murdoch are in love or
if this is like an implanted memory
because they stick you with a needle
straight in the skull out she talked
about how she they give you all these
new memories and then they completely
changed the city that's another thing
some of the effects are freaking awesome
this was made in 1998 some of the
effects rule at midnight everyone kind
of goes into this dormant state and like
goes to sleep and then they wake up like
nothing has happened which is so cool
and while they're asleep the city is
just transforming every single night and
they're injecting memories it's so cool
how it's done it's really interesting I
loved watching those bits but then
there's this other effect that looks so
weird you guys it's the power that the
strangers have and also John Murdock
coincidentally has they can do this
thing called tuning and it's you were
able to control things with just your
sheer will but they don't do anything
with their hands just their face and
they've got pretty blank faces all the
time the strangers and even John when he
does it and it's just this like
transparent wave that comes out of your
face so they're just looking at you and
it's just like not intimidating it's not
even that much it's kind of like that
that effect isn't great I'll say there's
a couple of things that the strangers do
that I find kind of silly like instead
of these hats
hello mr. Murdoch any B's has
hello mr. Murdoch
hello hello hello mr. Murdoch oh hello
Keifer Sutherlands came to speak it's so
weird
he talks like this and I have very
little time to stop do you right now I
have so much to tell you
spit it out buddy I really enjoyed him I
just I it got in longer sentences do you
get a little bit on my nerves I will be
very honest about that though again I
thought he was really good in it I think
the acting was killer some of the
strangers were a little weird okay I
take it back some of the strangers a
little odd but damned if it wasn't not
always odd I think the strangers had
their moments of scary just you know
strange as well in some instances
strangers what they were going for if
you would have showed me this two years
ago like if I would have started
Tamara's never seen with Dark City I
think I would have found it to be a
little overwhelming for my no nothing
film brain now though I really I found
such worth in it and it was so cool you
know what I'm gonna take that back I
think young Tamara would have super
loved this movie not coming at it but
like watching these movies I know that I
need to talk about how I feel about them
and like - I like it did I not like it
if I want to just watch this like you
know growing up I think oh my god I want
to flip and loved this movie it's so
weird and so cool it looks awesome
Jennifer Connelly's a goddess it just
it's really neat it's kind of hard to
come out this other than like it looks
pretty and it cools I wrote it's so
unsettling it's so good why do I feel
like I'm missing
something why do I feel like something's
missing it feels like I should have
watched I can special-edition that had
like the 12 extra minute it's a better
character work because I just I feel
like something's missing I don't know
what it is I don't know if it's the
relationships feel that they feel empty
John Murdock and Jennifer Connelly's
character they're married but you don't
get that much chemistry from them
there's this one moment where he Tunes
the glass he's in jail and they're
talking and then he breaks the glass and
they're kissing and it's like that's
cool I like the end would he like REME
eats her because her memories have gone
and he's now gonna like swoop her up and
fall in love with her he's like the god
of Dark City at this point that's cool
but I don't know I'm missing something
there I really think it's these
characters so Kiefer Sutherland gives
his old memories back to John Murdock
and then John knows how to tune well and
he defeats the strangers and he puts
them in a vat of water and the main
stranger like it has an allergic
reaction to water and he pulls like a
Wicked Witch of the West then John
Murdock makes Shell Beach with his mind
this tuning power and he recalls in love
with Emma / Anna and it's cool very
stylized so many themes such insanely
cool sets and characters I think maybe
the one thing that I just wish was ant
of a little is I know that John had to
kind of be this way because he didn't
know who he was as a whole point of the
movie but I missed having a lead
character that had a personality at all
I just didn't get much from him I think
he was a great actor I understand why it
had to be that way
but boo where complain whine I just want
a Christmas charismatic liya guarantor
overall I'm really glad that I saw this
I think it's really cool and I feel cool
for having watched it is that a thing
you watch a movie and you feel cool
because you've seen it thank you so much
for watching I will see you all next
week after I become one with Ike and I
will always love you
[Music]
[Applause]
you